let's uh bow our heads for word of prayer father
in heaven as we enter into the message tonight
i pray in the name of jesus you will
be with us in the person of your spirit
grant me the words to speak and grant your people
listening hearts hearts eager to receive the truth
i pray this in jesus name and for his sake amen in
exodus chapter 3 exodus chapter 3 our subject is
what is and where is the kingdom of god exodus
chapter 3 reading from verse nine exodus three
now therefore the cry of the children of israel is
common to me and i have also seen the oppression
wherewith the egyptians oppress them come now
therefore and i will send thee unto pharaoh
that thou must bring forth my people the
children of israel out of egypt now this is
god speaking to moses from the burning
bush and moses said unto god who am i
that i should go unto pharaoh and bring forth
the children of israel out of egypt and he said
certainly i will be with thee and this shall
be a token that i have sent thee when thou has
brought forth the people out of egypt thou shalt
serve god upon this mount and moses said unto god
verse 13 when i come unto the children of israel
and shall say unto them the god of your fathers
have sent me unto you and they shall say to
me what is his name what shall i say unto them
that tells us immediately that prolonged
exposure to egyptian culture had rendered
the large majority of israelites no longer
able to recall the name of their god
if we allow the world to influence us long enough
there are some critical things about our religion
that we will simply forget and so moses knowing
that the majority of his people had forgotten
what god's name was he asks a very reasonable
question when i come to the children of israel
and shall say unto them the god of your fathers
have sent me unto you and they shall say to me
what is his name what shall i say unto them
and god said unto moses verse 14 i am that i am
thus shall i say unto the children
of israel i am have sent me unto you
god identifies himself as i am this was
the god that spoke from the burning bush
this was the god of their fathers abraham
isaac and jacob now it's important for us
as we continue with what and where is the kingdom
of god to understand who i am is i am being of
course the self-existent one existing with no help
from anyone particularly pharaoh let's go to john
chapter eight
john chapter eight
we'll read verse i believe it's verse 56
john 8 56
this is jesus christ having one of
his usual arguments with the scribes
and the pharisees and jesus makes a statement
let's go to verse 58 actually he said your father
abraham rejoiced to see my day and he saw it
and was glad your father abraham he said rejoice
to see my and he saw it jesus says my day
so the jews were shell-shocked they said thou art
not yet 50 years old and hast thou seen abraham
then jesus made a statement that almost cost him
his life said verily verily i say unto you before
abraham what was finish it i am what is jesus
doing what does he reveal by making a statement
that he is god and that it was he who
appeared in the burning bush to moses
now we have to understand that the god
of the old testament is jesus christ
the same god that drowned the entire
egyptian army this was the same god
who was there on that cross
we have to understand that
and so when we read in verse three and the angel
of the lord appeared unto him in the flame of fire
gen exodus 3 verse 2 out of the midst of the bush
this was jesus christ because in verse 6 we read
moreover he said i am the god of thy father
the god of abraham the god of isaac and the
god of jacob and moses hid his face for
he was afraid to look upon whom upon god
jesus christ was the god who appeared
to moses in that burning bush
jesus christ it was who told moses go to pharaoh
and ask him to let my people go it was jesus
christ he wasn't called christ then just the son
second member of the godhead but let us be clear
the god of the old testament is
jesus christ can you say amen
someone said to me several years ago if you want
to learn about christ read the old testament
if you want to learn about the father read the
gospels because jesus not jesus did not come to do
his own will but whose will the will of the father
he came to reflect the father that's why he could
tell philip if he have seen me ye have seen the
father john 14 verse 9 and 10 verse 9. and if you
want to know about the holy spirit you read from
acts on through the epistles it was jesus christ
now let's read some more words about jesus
christ let's go to exodus chapter 19.
exodus 19 we shall read from verse 1 as we
continue what and where is the kingdom of
god and time seems to move so quickly when i
have what i consider a very important message
it's already 7 24. if anyone knows how to slow
time down please do that for me so i can have a
little more time genesis exodus 19 from verse 1
in the third month when the children of israel
were gone forth out of the land of egypt the same
day came there into the wilderness of sinai for
they were departed from referendum and will come
into the desert of sinai and had pitched in the
wilderness and the israel camp before the mount
this is mount sinai and moses went up unto god
and the lord called unto him out of the mountains
saying thus shalt thou say to the house of jacob
and tell the children of israel now reading from
verse 4 ye have seen what i did unto the egyptians
now what did god do to the egyptians 10 of these
what are these plagues and god says you saw ye
have seen what i did unto egyptians and how i bear
you on eagle's wings and brought you unto whom
myself when god saves you he saves
you with a divinely selfish motive
if i can put those two words together he
saves you so that you may be entirely his
god does not share what he has with the
world by the world i mean that sinful system
run by the devil god brought
them out of egypt unto himself
now therefore if ye will obey my voice indeed
verse 5 and will do what keep my covenant then
ye shall be a peculiar treasure unto me above
all nations or all people for all the earth is
mine now read verse 5 again let's view that verse
very carefully now therefore if ye will obey
my voice indeed and keep my covenant then i've
told you many times you're probably sick to
death of hearing me god is a god of process
he's a god of one step before the other he's
the god of order he's systematic therefore if
ye obey my voice indeed if he keep my covenant
then he shall be a peculiar treasure meaning
something that belongs to him very specially
above how many people all people for all
the earth is mine god is saying even though
everyone on earth is mine by virtue of creation
the bible says the earth is the lord's and the
fullness thereof the world and they that dwell
therein psalm 24 1 by virtue of creation every
living person under the earth son belongs to god
by virtue of creation not by virtue of salvation
am i clear by virtue of creation not by salvation
salvation you've got to choose christ but god says
you shall be a peculiar treasure unto
me above all people meaning that in
israel god would have the only
people keeping his commandments
because all the others were not
i want that to sink in listen to the verse again
i tend to speak quickly when i have little time
and i'm excited and i see people who love
the word fatal combination now therefore
if he will obey my voice indeed and keep
my covenant and i will proceed momentarily
to identify the covenant then ye shall be a
peculiar treasure unto me hear the israelites
above all people in other words the earth is
divided into the israelites and everybody else
do you see that it may not be politically
correct but that's what the verse says
the israelites and everyone else and god wants
the israelites to be the example of obedience
to his word and god said those who do that
who obey me will be a special treasure unto me
how many of us want to be special
to god can i see your hands
oh god bless you your hands whirls up like
quick growing grass let me tell you something
you cannot be special to god
in a life of disobedience
i don't care how well you dress how
many sabbaths you attend church how
much time you give if the life is a life of
disobedience a life disregarding god's word
we cannot be a special treasure
unto god the specialness of our
relationship with god is based on our
heartfelt obedience to his commandments
verse 6 and you shall be
unto me a kingdom of priests
what kind of priest a kingdom of priests and
what kind of nation a holy nation kingdom
nation same thing priests take care of holy things
a holy nation is a kingdom of priests same thing
for all practical purposes this was christ's
intention when he sent moses to get the israelites
god always has a purpose many times we do things
for no good reason simply because we have nothing
else to do that's why a lot of people are behind
bars but god always has a reason for what he does
and so he brought them out that there might
be a special treasure to him by the keeping
of his commandments and his covenant now what is
the covenant stay in the book of exodus chapter
34 verses 27 and 28 as we continue what and where
is the kingdom of god exodus 34 verses 27 and 28.
how many of us are here for
the first time ice your hands
god bless you thank you very much for coming
those of you who've never missed one session
afternoon or evening let me see your hands
god bless you i have not missed any either
and we're happy for that all right do you have
exodus 34 verse 27 28 and the lord said unto moses
write thou these words for after the tenor of
these words i have made what a covenant with thee
and with israel the tenor they made simply
according to these words on the basis of
these words in the light of these words
and he was there with the lord 40 days
and 40 nights he did neither eat bread
nor drink water and he wrote on the tables
the words of what the covenant and what
was the covenant the ten commandments
let's go to deuteronomy chapter four let's
read verse 12 7 31 deuteronomy 4 verse 12.
deuteronomy the fifth book of the
bible the last book of the pentateuch
chapter 4 verse 12 and the lord spake
unto you out of the midst of the fire
he heard the voice of the
words but saw no similitude
only he heard a voice and he declared unto you his
what which he commanded you to want perform even
even ten commandments and he wrote them
upon two tables of stone the covenant
is the ten commandments you see every
kingdom must have a constitution
god's kingdom has won and the constitution in
heaven is the constitution for god's people
on earth because god's people on earth are
merely an extension of the kingdom in heaven
come on i need more amends i will
beg until i leave here march the 10th
the kingdom on earth is but an extension of god's
kingdom in heaven consequently the constitution
that is the foundation of god's kingdom
in heaven is the same constitution
that must be the foundation of god's kingdom on
earth now we know that there are 48 states in
continental united states hawaii is thousands
of miles away is it part of the united states
does it have a different constitution no same
constitution same government but separated by
thousands of miles heaven we don't know how many
light years away it is the earth the distance
makes no difference the constitution in heaven is
the constitution on earth and that constitution
is the ten commandments are you listening to
me let me tell you something else about this
constitution that is the foundation of god's
kingdom it was not written by god and man
god did not have any input from mankind
doesn't need it the constitution was written
entirely by god and what god does he sends out
invitations to come and be a part of this kingdom
and the only requirement for participation
and citizenship in this kingdom is conformity
to his law through faith in jesus christ
and god is so eager that we be part of his kingdom
god sent his son jesus to show us that
admission into his kingdom is eminently possible
the standards for admission
are possible to a human being
born in sin and shaped in iniquity born
after the image of adam after he fell
and so jesus came and by a
life of victory he demonstrated
that all those who will
accept him by faith and live
as he lived by holding on to the father
may be admitted into that kingdom of glory
and so jesus said in john 14 verse 1 let not your
heart be troubled you believe in god believe also
in me in my father's house are many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you i go
to prepare a place for you and if i go to
prepare a place for you i will come again
and receive you unto myself that where i am there
you may be also then he says in verse 4 and with
i go ye no and the way ye know in other words you
know where i'm going and you know how to get there
now getting there does not
require geographical directions
that's not how you get to heaven you don't need
to go to mapquest to find out how to get from
here to heaven so jesus says and whether i go
ye no and the way he know thomas says unto him
lord we know not without goest and how can we
know the way how does one get to heaven jesus
said you know how to get to heaven jesus said
in verse 6 i am the way the truth and the life
the same way i am going to heaven is the same
way you go to heaven i lived like you i held
on tenaciously to my father's power i overcame
he has accepted my sacrifice i am going back
you follow me the same way through my example by
faith in me that's how you find your way to heaven
so i'm going to prepare the way for you that is a
statement of faith because these were 11 men who
would run from him eleven would run in the garden
of gethsemane one would betray him yet jesus has
faith he has confidence it's a beautiful concept
to think that jesus has faith in us remember when
he said simon simon simon satan has desired
to tempt you as weak but i has i have prayed
for thee that thy faith will not and when thou
art converted strengthen the brethren jesus is
telling peter you will be tested you'll be tried
you'll betray me but i know you'll come through
that is divine having confidence in the human when
the human holds on to the divine and so jesus says
i go to prepare a place for you because i believe
you will make it there through faith in me now
the kingdom of god i say has one constitution
when jesus was before pilate in john 18 pilate
asked him a question in verse 35. pilate said
thine o nation and the chief priest hath
delivered thee unto me what hast thou done
in verse 36 the bible says jesus answered
my kingdom is not of this world did he mean
pilate was a ruler in an earthly kingdom and he
was surrounded by all the trappings roman seal
roman guard roman palace the power of life and
death in his hand roman troops all over jerusalem
under his command all the signs of an earthly
kingdom and jesus said to this earthly ruler
my kingdom is not of this world he goes
on to say if my kingdom were of this world
then would my servants fight that i
should not be delivered to the jews
but now is my kingdom not from hence you see
let me point something out to you when you
are a member of the kingdom of christ you do not
use the methods of the world it's in that verse
listen to what jesus says if my kingdom were
of this world then would my servants do what
fight that's how the romans did it they fought
that's how the babylonians did it they fought
the middle persians did it they fought that's how
the alexandria the the greeks did it they fought
that's how earthly nations defend
their sovereignty they fight
and christians must not use the ways of the
world jesus says in my kingdom people don't fight
that's for your kingdom pilate not mine
if my kingdom were of this world meaning
if my kingdom were worldly earthly
then would my servants fight
but now is my kingdom not from thence the kingdom
of jesus christ is both literal and spiritual
there is a new jerusalem in heaven
a city someone told me a few days ago it
is estimated the city is the size of oregon
well if no amends you might at least
smile who has a city the size of oregon
the city god has prepared for us there's a
space station up there somewhere am i right
astronauts go up and down live there for
six months they take food grocery supplies
corn flakes milk soy milk and they go up and down
they live in heaven if human beings can do that
why can't my god build a city in heaven if human
beings can stay on the earth and communicate
with the satellite millions of miles in space
why can't i kneel on my knees and pray and
god hear me as though he's right next to me
god has a physical and a spiritual kingdom this
spiritual kingdom is the kind of life required
of a citizen of the kingdom and that life is a
righteous life it is based on the constitution
i watched the uh the inauguration on january
whenever it was 20. and president bush raised
his right hand and he swore to do what
defend what uphold what the constitution
he swore to uphold the constitution
any person convicted on a law
found to be unconstitutional is
then what happens to that person
you're set free any law determined to be
unconstitutional is supposed to be removed
from the books because the constitution is the
ultimate standard in this country of what's right
and what's wrong what's legal and what's illegal
the ten commandments are god's constitution
and they are required as the standard of
living for those in heaven now and as the
standard of living for those on the earth now
who are part of the extended kingdom of god
and so when jesus said my kingdom is
not of this world he's not saying my
kingdom is not on the earth it is on
the earth in the lives of his people
and so you and i represent the kingdom
of god and based on what jesus says my
kingdom is not of this world for if my kingdom
were of this world then with my servants fight
we understand from that statement that we must
live our lives and take care of our business in
a way that is vastly different from the way the
world does it because we are not of this world
and in praying to his father in john 17 jesus
says in verse 14 i have given them thy word and
the world hath hated them because they are
not of this world let me say something here
if the church is getting along fine
with the world something is not right
i just thought to say that had i thought earlier i
might have gotten the quotation of ellen white she
said the only reason the church is not persecuted
because the church is just like the world
this one
i said this one i didn't say you i said this
one and it is sad because when we drift from the
constitution of the kingdom of god we become like
the world because there are only two constitutions
god's commandments and the anti-commandments
which is be saved and then live as you like
that's the constitution of the
world god's constitution is
the standard of righteousness unequal in the
cosmos vast limitless and that is the expression
of the righteousness of god himself and that
expression is the ten commandments and jesus came
and put flesh and bones on the
ten commandments in his life
and now he says to you you know the way as i
lived you live that's the way to the kingdom
faith in jesus christ of whom it is said i delight
to do thy will o my god yea thy law is on two
pieces of stone you must correct me quickly i'm
being taped yea thy law is where within my heart
and that goes back to the sanctuary we talked
about earlier today 745 the sanctuary was two
compartments the holy the most holy in the most
holy was the ark a three layered box wood in the
middle gold on the inside gold on the outside ten
commandments in there covered by the mercy sea
the throne of god verse 22 exodus 25 moses tell
god tells moses and i there i will meet with thee
and i will commune with thee from above the mercy
seat from between the two cherubims which are upon
the ark of the testimony and and all things which
i shall give thee in commandment unto the children
of israel everything i say i will say as the
sovereign of the universe sitting from my throne
our president is called a sitting president why
because he is currently in office he is a sitting
president god sits on his throne i'm not
saying god never moves it has symbolic meaning
it means god is always in control god
never has term limits are you following me
in four years george w bush can no longer run
for president he will be a former president no
longer sitting in the final two years he will be
a lame duck president god is not a lame duck god
he is a god he's an active god a supreme
god a ruler a sovereign and i say again
the constitution of his kingdom is
the ten commandments and that must be
the constitution for his kingdom on earth
and the constitution in our private lives
the ten commandments that most people don't like
i'm always puzzled why people object to
the ten commandments can you imagine a man
going to the police station maybe the loma
linda police tells the officer sergeant i
have a complaint to make the death sergeant
said what is it no one breaks into my house
my car is parked on the road no one
steals it what kind of a town is this
or some man goes to his priest he confesses
i've been married to my wife 15 years and
the woman is faithful i don't understand
what's wrong with this woman she's faithful
the commandments of god are for our happiness
somebody say amen they are for our happiness our
security but when people attack the commandments
let me tell you secret 47 30 minutes to eight
they are attacking the sabbath satan is sufficient
that he is willing to destroy all ten to get one
so when people say the commandments are
done away with we're living under grace
you ask them does that mean i can kill
you now no no no no can i take your wife
can i break into your house
tonight steal your jewelry no
but then what precisely do you mean the
commandments have been done away with
silence it is a satanic argument to undermine
the commandment that truly expresses the
sovereignty of god the his right to rule in
this kingdom of righteousness because he made it
he made it and at the heart of this
constitution is the sabbath commandment
that explains where we came from where the
universe came from and gives us why god has the
right to sit on that throne and i have something
to say about the sabbath before i leave here
maybe thursday maybe i'll mix them on friday by
the way i'll talk more about living above sin
on friday evening let's go to second peter
chapter 3 i'm saying i'm trying to say as
many things as i can second peter chapter 3
reading from verse 10 as we continue what is
and where is the kingdom of god the kingdom of god
is that kingdom of right living according to god's
commandments and it is right here on this earth
being an extension of god's kingdom in heaven
ii peter chapter 3 reading from verse 10 where the
day of the lord will come as a thief in the night
into which the heavens shall pass away with
a great noise and the element shall melt with
fervent heat the earth also and the works that
are therein shall be burned up seeing then that
all these things shall be dissolved what manner
of persons ought to be in all holy conversation
and godliness looking for and hasting unto
the coming of the day of the god wherein the
heavens being on fire shall be dissolved and the
elements shall melt with fervent heat now verse 13
peter writes nevertheless we according to his
promise look for what new heavens go on and
new earth wearing dwelleth wearing dwelleth one
more time wearing dwelleth righteousness now
jesus said i've gone to prepare a place
it's a righteous place i told you god works by
procedure he works by a step-by-step process
before moses could leave the israelites for 40
years what did he have to leave for 40 years sheep
before adam could be certified safe
what did god have to put him through
a test before god could destroy sodom and
gomorrah who whom did he have to remove lot
before destroying nineveh what did he have to do
send the warning one thing comes before the other
and before we are admitted to new heavens and
new earth wherein dwelleth righteousness we must
demonstrate on this earth that we can live the
righteous life we're expected to live over there
this must come first god must see that those
applying for positions in his kingdom if i can put
it that way they must demonstrate their fitness
for that kingdom by living the kingdom life now
i'm not sure i said that clearly i did
well just in case let me say it again
it is so serious listen to me
no one sets foot into that kingdom
who has not lived a kingdom life now
heaven is not a place to learn how to live
right the earth is the place to do that not
just to learn but to master it let me
say it again to learn and to master it
because jesus isn't coming to save people
from sin he's coming to collect those who've
already overcome sin how much sin all sin
well let me talk to this side how much sin
let's keep things balanced here my beloved
brothers and sisters this is so serious
earth is the place where we learn to
live like christ not heaven and no one
was set foot in a righteous world peter says
wherein dwelleth righteousness lives in the
new world when god comes back makes
this world brand new revelation 21 1
and i saw and you have a new earth for the
first heaven and the first earth will pass away
in that new world where there shall
be no hurt and all my holy mountain
righteousness reigns and dwelts consequently
we must be righteous to be admitted
and that righteousness is the very
righteousness expressed in the law
that is why the bible says god sending his son
in the likeness of sinful flesh and forcing
condemned sin in the flesh that the righteousness
of the law might be what fulfilled where in us
who walked not after the flesh but after the
spirit and that's where we make the mistake
we long to live in a righteous world while
we walk after the flesh it doesn't work
that's like washing your hands and
drying them in dirt it does not work
if we long to live in a righteous
world we must walk after the spirit
i say again how many of us want to seek god's
face and live in heaven can i show your hands
i believe you yes we do and when i say heaven
i really mean this earth we'll only be there
a thousand years you know that now perhaps we'll
visit back and forth i don't know but we'll be a
thousand years we come back this is where we live
the earth made new when god made adam he put him
here not up there so this is eden restored we want
to live in a world where people don't lock doors
you don't have to some lovely lady she's sitting
in the front gave me a ride today in her limousine
she gave me a great blessing at the loma linda
market i won't say what it is it's our secret for
life and we'll talk about it in the new world and
uh she had a a metal thing on the steering wheel
of the car i don't know what you call it was it
a ho a what a club sounds violent okay a club
and i said to her why do you need
this club on loma linda's campus
that was my question i saw a sign in the loma
linda market parking lot lock your car okay why
i thought we were good adventists but apparently
there's some who are not in the new world in which
christ is making you don't have to put a club on
your chariot no one will steal your horses you
don't need an alarm system on your door because
the only people coming in and out are the angels
you don't need neighborhood watch
you don't need chapel credit let the church say
amen my brothers and sisters were smiling and
smiling as good laughter with good luck a medicine
at five minutes to eight but i need to tell you
that we need to treasure and to long for a
righteous life which is not simply what you
do that's the second level of righteousness the
first level is who you are that's why god takes
his law you know jesus said i'd like to do
thy will oh my god ye thy lawyers within my
heart i told you a few days ago god writes
his constitution on every citizen's heart
and so we find great joy in being law
abiding citizens of the kingdom the world
needs to see the kingdom of god in action and
the world must see it in our lives as a church
and our lives as individual because we live
by kingdom principles not earthly principles
jesus said in john 8 23 to the scribes and
pharisees here from beneath i'm from above
ear of this world i am not of this world he said
of his disciples he said the same thing john 17 16
there are not of this world
even as i am not of this world
now that's a tremendous comparison the same way
jesus says that i am different from this world
my disciples are different from this world all
children of god raise your right hand quickly
we don't have a lot of time good we
must be different from this world
i should not learn what the latest fashion
is in the world by coming to church
i shall not learn what the latest rap song is by
listening to the young people in the
parking lot right after midday service
because we're different you know people laugh
at the amish you know the amish in pennsylvania
because the way they dress and they run right
around in horse and buggy but let me tell
you something when the amish sell food stuff
people buy them you know why they trust them
if these people will hold on so faithfully to
their way of life you can trust anything they do
can the world trust us don't
answer me can the world trust us
god wants to put his kingdom in
your heart tonight if it's not there
with its constitution written not
on tables of stone as in exodus 20
but on the fleshy tables of the
heart second corinthians 3 verse 3.
how many of you will say with me lord i want
to be a citizen in your kingdom beginning now
let me see your hand here's what i want you to
do two minutes to eight give me five more please
write on your card
all you need to write on that card is a large k
i desire with all my heart god loves decisions
you always told his people choose one way or
the other he loves decisions when
we make decisions for christ we get
into the habit of making decisions
for christ it's a mental discipline
you write on that card a large k kingdom i
want to be in the kingdom of god i want to
be a citizen of that kingdom beginning
now on this earth just right okay
if you want bible studies check that box you
want to meet with me one-on-one check that box i
believe tomorrow we shall have sign up sheets
the one-on-one counseling begins on sunday
i think it's nine to five on sunday one to eight
monday through wednesday and of course i depart on
thursday so be sure to sign up i don't know if the
sheets are ready perhaps not but they'll certainly
be here tomorrow but on that card a large k i want
to be a citizen of the kingdom and live by the
principles of the constitution god's sacred law
that expresses his character precisely a law that
works at the very level of motive and thought long
before i get to the level of action and behavior
you see in the kingdom of god god deals with
sin in the kingdom of caesar he deals with crime
as one of our pioneers said you killed someone
you've committed a crime in the kingdom of god
you just have to think it and you've committed a
sin that's a higher level of living large k i want
to be a citizen paul says in philippians 3 20 for
our conversation or lifestyle or citizenship is
in heaven from whence also we look for the savior
where christ is coming from is where our heart is
and all those who say with me
father help me by my daily life
to reflect the principles of
the constitution of your kingdom
stand to your feet please and i want
you to be serious as i try to be please
if we're not reflecting the principles of that
constitution we are bearing false witness against
our neighbor because we're saying one thing
and doing something else the bible says thou
shalt not bear false witness let me say it again
if the world knows adventists believe so and so
and we don't live it we are bearing false witness
and also taking the name of the lord our god
in vain but i believe with all my heart that
you and i are serious tonight lord rewrite
your constitution on my heart so i just have my
impulses become holy my instincts become righteous
my first reaction is a holy one that is what
happens when that which is of the spirit is spirit
and that which is born of the flesh is flesh when
we are all spirit our instincts are like jesus
ah let's bow our heads please our eyes closed
father i come to you in the name of jesus
i beg you with all my heart and soul lord to
receive us for the sake of our savior who came
live the kingdom life and has left the way for
us to follow him and that way is his life which
we accept by faith and we live out through the
power of the father lord i ask you to have mercy
on us and forgive us for the times we have
misrepresented what the kingdom stands for
we have talked about the kingdom with our lips but
we have not represented it in our lives and we're
sorry dig out from our hearts all that
is unlike you and unlike your kingdom
so that we at every level of our lives in
details large and small might behave ourselves
and think and speak and respond like a citizen
of the kingdom though we now live on the earth
lord please hear us hear us i pray
father we're living in dangerous times
and we need the assurance that we're safe
under your wing lord grant us your spirit
that the spirit might bear witness with our spirit
that we are the children of god we need that
testimony from heaven as you testify that abel was
righteous as you testify that noah's righteous or
father testify tonight that we're righteous
and we indeed are citizens of your kingdom
lord hear this humble prayer i plead for my heart
bless my brothers and sisters who love your word
so much they come night after night take them
home safely and bring us back tomorrow i pray
in jesus name and for his sake let all citizens of
god's kingdom say with me amen and amen god bless
you god bless you travel safely and we shall see
you tomorrow evening and tomorrow early afternoon